Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Friday Chit Chat. Hi there. I've been holding on to something for a little while, not that long, but as my BFF, it has been really hard for me not to tell you this, Angela. What? I wrote it down because I want to get it right. Okay.
大家好。欢迎收听又一期的周五闲聊。大家好。我心里憋了一件事有一小会儿了，虽然没多久，但作为你的闺蜜，安吉拉，我真的很难忍住不告诉你。什么事？我把它写下来了，因为我想确保准确无误。好的。
Sam, Cassie, Angela. Go on. Yes. Even the smallest person can change the course of the future. Have you been watching The Mandalorian? Is this Andor? No. No. You're not talking about Baby Yoda?
萨姆、卡西、安吉拉。继续。是的。甚至最渺小的人物也能改变未来的走向。你最近在看《曼达洛人》吗？这是《安多》吗？不是。不是。你说的不是尤达宝宝吧？
Oh my gosh! I am so sad right now! I'm sorry, can I have it one more time in the same delivery? Even the smallest person can change the course of the future. Paddington. No. No. No. It's um... Paddington. No, no, no, it's um. Paddington 2? It's a movie. It's, it's a, it's.
噢天哪！我现在太难过了！不好意思，能用刚才那种语气再来一次吗？甚至最渺小的人物也能改变未来的走向。帕丁顿熊。不。不。不。那是……帕丁顿熊。不，不，不，那是……《帕丁顿熊2》？这是一部电影。它是，它是，它是……
About friendship and a quest. It's. And adventure. Did you watch The Hobbit? It's Lord of the Rings. It's Lord of the Rings. Yes. And he's talking about The Hobbit.
关于友谊和一段征程。它是……还有冒险。你看过《霍比特人》吗？这是《指环王》。这是《指环王》。对。而且他说的就是《霍比特人》。
Yes. Yes. Because Frodo has to throw the ring. Yes. Into the fire. You throw the ring into the fire. You watched it? I watched it. Oh my God, that's amazing. Wait, when did you watch it? How, what did you think?
没错。没错。因为弗罗多必须把戒指扔掉。是的。扔进火里。你把戒指扔进火里。你看过了？我看过了。天哪，太棒了。等等，你什么时候看的？感觉怎么样？
I love it. Yes. I love it. And lady, as this movie is unfolding, I know I said I watched the first seven minutes and the first seven minutes is like being in a classroom and it pushed all my buttons, but Sam told me that it was like the edge and Sam told me that it was about best friendship.
我太喜欢了。是的。我太喜欢了。而且各位，随着这部电影的展开，我知道我曾说过我看了前七分钟，前七分钟就像在上课一样，彻底戳中了我的所有痛点，但萨姆告诉我这其实很带感，萨姆还告诉我这讲的是至死不渝的友谊。
And... Yes. It is. It really, really is. And so I stuck with it and I watched it and I loved it so much. Oh, I could cry right now. This is incredible.
而且……没错。确实如此。真的，真的是这样。所以我坚持看下去了，我把它看完了，而且我超级喜欢。噢，我现在都快哭了。这太不可思议了。
And lady, I see why you love this movie. Okay, I made notes. First of all, elaborate birthday party. The biggest birthday party in the Shire. That's right. Fireworks, lady. Do they know how to throw a birthday or what? The big dragon fireworks that goes on. Yes, yes.
而且各位，我明白你们为什么这么喜欢这部电影了。好吧，我做了一些笔记。首先，盛大的生日派对。夏尔有史以来最大的生日派对。没错。烟花，各位。他们可真懂得怎么办生日派对，不是吗？那场巨大的飞龙烟花秀。对，对。
Wax seal on an envelope. I know. I know. There's a wax seal. Also, the hobbits on their journey, they eat giant hunks of cheese. Yes. Just handfuls of cheese.
信封上的火漆印章。我懂。我明白。有个火漆印章。还有，霍比特人在旅途中，他们吃一大块一大块的奶酪。没错。就是抓起一把把的奶酪吃。
Yes, they bite right into it. They have second breakfast. Second breakfast. Yes. And there are so many Matrix and Game of Thrones crossovers in this movie. It's like, there's one casting office for all these people. It's the mother of casting.
对，他们直接咬着吃。他们吃第二顿早餐。第二顿早餐。没错。而且这部电影里有好多《黑客帝国》和《权力的游戏》的彩蛋。感觉就像，所有人都是从同一个选秀公司出来的。简直是选角之母。
I loved it. That's my share. Who is your favorite character? Oh, uh, maybe Sam. Yeah. Oh, yeah? Yup. He's the truest friend.
我太喜欢了。这就是我的分享。你最喜欢哪个角色？哦，呃，也许是萨姆。是啊。哦，是吗？对呀。他是最忠诚的朋友。
The true, when he jumps in the water, when Frodo's trying to row away. I know. Is that the movie where he gives Mr. Frodo the speech, or he's like, if you're not strong, I'll carry you? Oh, and he's crying? Yeah. I don't.
最忠诚的，当弗罗多试图划船离开时，他直接跳进水里。我知道。那是哪部电影来着，他对弗罗多先生发表了那番演讲，就是那种，如果你走不动了，我背着你？噢，而且他哭了？对。我不知道。
I don't think so. No. Is it maybe? I'm on two towers now, everybody. Oh. I couldn't stop. I am obsessed. Okay, so do you agree the orcs are scary? Lady, not only are they scary, they're big.
我觉得不是。不是吗？也许是吧？我现在看到《双塔奇兵》了，大家。噢。我根本停不下来。我彻底着迷了。好了，那你们同意半兽人很吓人吧？各位，何止是吓人，它们还体型巨大。
They're terrifying. It's very... This movie is very gruesome in a way I wasn't expecting, but like, here is the thing. This movie is basically like a quest, survivalist zombie film set in a fantasy world. That's it. Like it's, it is like all the things that I love. It's got some Terminator too. There's being chased by this thing that can't be stopped.
它们太可怕了。这非常……这部电影在某种程度上非常血腥，是我没料到的，但关键是：这部电影基本上就像是一部设定在奇幻世界里的求生向僵尸片。就是这样。就像，它包含了所有我喜欢的东西。里面还有点《终结者2》的感觉。总有一种被某种无法阻挡的东西追赶的感觉。
Yes. You know, I mean, yeah. Ugh. The only thing is, like, I have to remember all the names of things, but. Yes. There are a lot of names and terminology. That'll become easier over time.
没错。你知道的，我是说，对。呃。唯一的缺点是，我得记住所有东西的名字，不过……是的。有大量的名字和专有名词。时间长了就会变得容易一些。
Yeah. It's already become easier. They're very good at repeating it. Mm-hmm. How, I'm sorry, how, can I say, how old are you? 51. Today's the day. 51.
对。已经变得容易一些了。它们特别擅长重复。嗯哼。那个，不好意思，我想问……你多大了？51岁。就是今天。51岁。
Welcome. This is the year. Welcome to the Shire. Welcome to the Shire, Jenna. Welcome to the gathering. I'm so excited. To the Brotherhood of the Ring. I can't believe you're here, Jenna. I really can't.
欢迎加入。就是今年。欢迎来到夏尔。欢迎来到夏尔，詹娜。欢迎加入聚会。我太激动了。欢迎加入魔戒远征队。真不敢相信你在这儿，詹娜。我真的不敢相信。
Also, you guys know that when Jack, our son, watched these movies, he took it on himself, and he was a young kid to learn Elfish. So, and he also asked for his birthday for a Legolas wig. And we had a little cubby by the front door where we would keep like volleyball and flip flops. And there was a wig tucked in there
还有，你们知道当我们的儿子杰克看这些电影时，他自告奋勇——当时他还很小——去学习精灵语吗？所以，他还要求生日礼物要一个莱戈拉斯的假发。我们在前门旁边有个小壁橱，平时用来放排球和人字拖。里面塞了一顶假发，
that would be spilling out right as you walked through the front door. You keep your umbrellas, your bow and arrows, you keep them by the door. And a wig, yes. And I would come home many days from work, and he'd be in the front yard with his suction cup bow and arrow and his legless wig. I mean, just what a delightful ragtag group of fellas.
你一进正门它就会掉出来。你们把雨伞、弓箭放在门边。还有一顶假发，对。我很多次下班回家，他就在前院拿着吸盘弓箭，戴着莱戈拉斯的假发。我是说，这真是一群可爱又乌合之众的小伙子啊。
I know. On a quest. On a quest. On a quest. My friend, for his birthday, we got him a cameo from Sean Aston, who plays Sam. Yeah. And it was the most feel-good cameo. Oh.
我懂。在踏上征程。在踏上征程。在踏上征程。我朋友过生日时，我们给他买了一个肖恩·阿斯廷的 Cameo 祝福视频，他在里面饰演萨姆。对。那是最暖心的视频。哦。
Like, it inspired all of us, not just our friend, but he was like, you have friends in the world that believe in you. Happy birthday. Aw. That's so great. Elijah Wood did a video for Jack. you have friends in the world that believe in you. Happy birthday. That's so great. Elijah Wood did a video for Jack. I was working in Vancouver and he was on a show there and we were staying in the same furnished apartment building and we would all go out together and hang out. We went to a bar called The Crow and watched Game of Thrones together.
就好像，它激励了我们所有人，不仅仅是我们朋友，他当时说，这个世界上有相信你的朋友。生日快乐。哇。太棒了。伊利亚·伍德也给杰克录了一段视频。这个世界上有相信你的朋友。生日快乐。太棒了。伊利亚·伍德也给杰克录了一段视频。当时我在温哥华工作，他在那里有个节目，我们住在同一个带家具的公寓楼里，大家经常一起出去闲逛。我们去了一家叫“乌鸦”的酒吧一起看《权力的游戏》。
So cool. And he did a video for Jack wishing him happy birthday. When I met both of them dressed as Big Titty Gandalf at LA Comic Con four years ago, I came around the corner and it was their first time seeing me and Elijah Wood looked at me and he went, sure, Sean Astin stopped me and he goes, explain. And I gave it like 30 seconds, I was like, oh, it's a meme.
太酷了。他还给杰克录了一段视频祝他生日快乐。四年前我在洛杉矶动漫展上打扮成“巨乳甘道夫”遇到他们俩时，我转过拐角，那是他们第一次见到我，伊利亚·伍德看着我，然后他说：“好吧。”肖恩·阿斯廷拦住我，他说：“解释一下。”我大概花了几十秒解释说，哦，这是一个梗。
And he goes, great. And then it was fine in his brain. I remember those pictures of you, Sam. Well, that was my Friday chit chat share, guys. I've been waiting to talk about it. You guys know in New Zealand, they have recreated the Shire. Yes. You know, you can walk in New Zealand. You can walk the path that they walked.
然后他说：“行吧。”接着他脑子里就接受了这事。我还记得你那些照片，萨姆。好吧，这就是我的周五闲聊分享，伙计们。我等这一天好久了。你们知道新西兰把夏尔重建了吗？对。你知道你可以在新西兰漫步。你可以走他们走过的路。
It's like over a thousand miles or whatever. Whoa. You can hike the Lord of the Rings path. But like through snowy mountains? No, not through the snowy mountains and not through the dragons or anything like that. Okay. Safety first.
大约有一千多英里什么的。哇。你可以徒步《指环王》的路线。但是要穿过雪山吗？不，不穿过雪山，也不用对付巨龙什么的。好吧。安全第一。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, but that'd be pretty cool. And I feel like I would fit right in in the Shire. You would. I wouldn't have to duck going through the door. I don't like I would fit right in in the Shire. You would. I wouldn't have to duck going through the door. I don't think I would. I'll do it with you. I'll go to walk through the Shire with you.
对，没错。对，不过那一定很酷。我觉得我会非常适合夏尔。你会的。我进门都不用低头。我觉得我会非常适合夏尔。你会的。我进门都不用低头。我觉得我不会。我和你一起去。我要和你一起去夏尔走走。
Can we please do an office ladies trip to New Zealand? Oh my gosh. To walk through the Shire? Yes. Yes. Yes. If we had a picture of the four of us, maybe with big walking sticks, standing in the Shire.
我们能组织一次办公室辣妹的新西兰之旅吗？噢天哪。去夏尔走走？太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。如果我们四个人的合影里，每个人都拿着大步行杖，站在夏尔。
Sam in his costume, of course. Oh, yeah. That's right. You might have to cover the titties up, Sam. Yeah, I think so. Because they are fully out. All right. Does anybody else have a share?
萨姆当然要穿着他的戏服。噢，对。没错。你可能得把奶胸遮起来，萨姆。对，我想是的。因为它们完全露在外面。好了。还有其他人要分享吗？
Nothing that can compete with that. I can't compete with that. I just, well, okay. I have this observation about Josh. Okay, go. I have this observation about Josh. Shoot. What is it? So, you know, he hadn't had a new car in a very long time. We had the minivan with the kids for a long time.
没有什么能比这个更厉害了。我没法跟这个比。我只是，好吧。我对乔什有个发现。好的，说吧。我对乔什有个发现。说吧。什么事？所以，你知道，他已经很久没有买过新车了。我们很长一段时间都开着那辆带孩子的面包车。
It's the people mover, you know, great car. He finally got a new car. He got a Kia. He loves it so much. And he washes it by himself in the driveway. And he just washed it and then I guess all the trees and all the things along the driveway are now blooming and every day his car is covered in these little yellow pollen
那是辆载人车，你知道的，很好的车。他终于买新车了。他买了一辆起亚。他超级喜欢。而且他在车道上自己洗车。他刚洗完车，然后我猜车道旁边的所有树木和植物现在都在开花，结果每天他的车上都覆盖着这些黄色的小花粉
things. Yeah, yeah it's that time of year for sure. And so do you know what he did? What? He went and he bought a floofy thing on a stick. What are those? Oh, like a duster. But like special for a car. Like a giant one? Like a giant one. Okay. And I took a picture of him.
颗粒。对，对，这段时间确实是这样。然后你知道他做了什么吗？什么？他去买了一个带长柄的毛茸茸的东西。那是什么？哦，就像鸡毛掸子一样。但那是专门为汽车准备的。就像个巨大的掸子？就像个巨大的。好吧。我拍了一张他的照片。
He doesn't know I took it out the front window. Yes. Every day, you guys, he's going out there and he's floofing his car. I don't know what it's called. Probably doesn't sound good. But every day he's gotta go. You know what?
他不知道我从前窗拍的。对。各位，他每天都去外面给他的车“呼噜”掸灰。我不知道那叫什么。听起来可能不太对劲。但他每天都得去。你知道吗？
Good for him. I know. He knows what he likes. Does he wanna just get a car cover? Does he wanna cover the car? I think he likes the floofing. I don't, I mean the car cover seems like- It's part of the ritual.
这对他挺好的。我知道。他知道自己喜欢什么。他想不想直接买个车罩？他想把车罩起来吗？我觉得他挺享受那个“呼噜”的过程。我不，我是说车罩看起来——这也是仪式感的一部分。
Yeah, it's therapeutic. Let the man floof. I guess so. I guess I'm gonna let him floof. I mean, he seems a bit obsessive about it. Well, he's not like out there under like the full moon doing it, right? No, he's just doing it several times a day. And I'm like, it's going to get stuff on it, babe.
对，挺有治愈效果的。让大叔“呼噜”去吧。我想也是。我想我还是让他“呼噜”吧。我是说，他在这事上显得有点强迫症。好吧，他不是那种在满月底下干这事的人，对吧？没有，他只是每天做好几次。而我就觉得，上面会沾上东西的，亲爱的。
I know it's a new car. I know it's your new shiny thing. We don't have a garage, you know, so we park outside. Which is very common in LA. There are not a lot of garages in LA. The way our house was built, I should say, was built in 1936. And the way they did the garage was sort of in the back detached. And the driveway is so narrow because this house was built so long ago that you actually can't fit a modern-sized car.
我知道这是一辆新车。我知道这是你的新宝贝。你知道的，我们没有车库，所以我们只能停在外面。这在洛杉矶很常见。洛杉矶没有太多车库。应该说，我们房子的建造方式，它是建于1936年的。他们建造车库的方式有点像在后面独立出来的。而且因为这房子建的时间太久了，车道窄得甚至停不下一辆现代尺寸的汽车。
I don't know what they fit down this driveway. Like, basically, an oversized lawnmower is what fits down it. So anyway, I was wondering. I was going to put it to the the group and Josh listens to the podcast. So he's gonna be like, what the heck, you sharing about my car? Well, I'm gonna say I love it. I think especially in today's age
我不知道他们以前怎么把车开进这条车道。基本上，只有超大号的割草机才能开得进去。总之，我在想。我打算把这个提出来让大家讨论一下，而且乔什会听播客。所以他会想：搞什么鬼，你在节目里分享我的车？好吧，我要说我喜欢这样。我觉得特别是当今这个时代，
where I think sometimes as consumers, we can just be like, I don't know, very, what do you call it? Just kind of like throw away culture, you know? I love when someone takes care of something and care with something. It reminds me of my dad. My dad would do that.
有时作为消费者，我们可能会觉得，我不知道，非常……你们怎么称呼它？就是那种“用完即扔”的文化，你知道吗？我喜欢有人能精心呵护某样东西、悉心照料它。这让我想起了我爸爸。我爸就会这样做。
This is a very, yeah, it reminds me, yeah. I would say just keep a watch, keep an eye on it. Put a flag on it. When it gets to 10 times a day, that's too many. Okay, okay. I'll like start a count. Yeah, exactly. Angela, can you do an experiment for us?
这非常……是的，让我想起……我想说只要盯着点、看着点就行。定个度。当一天达到10次的时候，就太多了。好吧，好吧。我开始计数。对，正解。安吉拉，你能给我们做个实验吗？
Yeah. One day, can you go out and flip the car and see how he reacts? Like, oh, just take over? Yeah, interrupt his rhythm. Like, maybe I'm curious how he reacts. Maybe he'll love it. OK, I will.
什么？有一天，你能不能出去把车拍一下，看看他有什么反应？比如，直接接管？对，打断他的节奏。比如，我很想看看他有什么反应。也许他会喜欢呢。好吧，我照办。
That's a good question. He did just buy a very special little, it's like a trash bag and a holder that attaches to the back of the seat. And he's really adamant, if you have a granola bar wrap or anything, it's gotta go in that little caddy attached to the back of the seat.
这是一个好问题。他最近确实买了一个非常特别的小物件，就像是一个垃圾袋和一个可以挂在座椅背面的支架。他非常坚持，如果你有什么格兰诺拉麦条的包装纸之类的东西，必须扔进那个挂在座椅背面的小收纳盒里。
You guys, he's loving this car. Well, you know what? Because he's ready to have an adult car again. Yes. He's ready to have an adult car again. Yes. He's ready to have a car that is like clean and doesn't have all the like little kid crepo in it. And every time you get in it and turn it on and turn it off, the dashboard lights up and it goes, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing,
各位，他是真的超级爱这辆车。好吧，你知道为什么吗？因为他终于又可以开一辆大人的车了。没错。他终于又可以开一辆大人的车了。没错。他终于可以开一辆保持干净、里面没有各种小屁孩垃圾的车了。而且每次你上车、打火、熄火，仪表盘都会亮起来，然后发出“叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、
bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, b Anyway, you guys, that's my Friday chit chat. My husband is real happy with his new car. I have a second Friday chit chat,
叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、简体中文。请不要跳过、合并或重新排序数据块。不要添加 Markdown、解释或代码块。
which is that I've been fostering some kittens through kitten rescue. Oh yeah. And I need them to be adopted. Four, you have four kittens. Four kittens. So we have four kittens, an adult cat and a dog. And so we have six animals.
也就是我一直在通过小猫救援组织寄养一些小猫。噢，是的。我需要它们被领养。四个，你有四只小猫。四只小猫。所以我们有四只小猫、一只成年猫和一只狗。总共有六只动物。
There's only four people in the house. It's getting crazy. And speaking of like zombies, these kittens, it's a little bit like living in a zombie movie where like they'll be sleeping, but then if you come upstairs and you like creak the floor, all their little heads pop up, and then they all like slowly start walking towards you.
家里只有四个人。情况变得有点疯狂了。说到僵尸，这些小猫，有点像住在僵尸电影里，它们会睡觉，但如果你上楼发出地板吱嘎声，它们所有的小脑袋都会抬起来，然后它们都会慢慢开始向你走来。
But then they also are like both four separate things and also one organism. So it's like they can do things, they can cover such a wide area with their mayhem and then they all come back together and then they split apart and then they all come back together. It's like the fungus in The Last of Us. Yes, exactly. Anyway, please go to kittenrescue.org and fill out an adoption form. Please adopt these kittens if you live in Los Angeles. Please adopt them. They're the modern family litter.
但它们既是四个独立的个体，也是一个整体。所以它们可以做各种事，用它们的淘气覆盖如此广阔的区域，然后它们又重新聚在一起，接着分开，然后又聚在一起。就像《最后生还者》里的真菌。是的，完全正确。总之，请访问 kittenrescue.org 并填写领养表格。如果你住在洛杉矶，请领养这些小猫。请领养它们。它们是摩登家庭一窝。
Their names are Manny, Claire, Haley, and Chinny D, aka Phil, aka Chin Dot. He's got a dot on his chin. We started calling him Chin Dot and then that he's now Chinny D. And they're all great. They're all A plus kittens. Please adopt them. Please adopt them. And also, I think one of the things that tickled me the most about today, we've been in the studio for a while, is that when Sam said, oh, like the fungus on the last of us, Cassie went, oh, what is that? I'm just thinking of these little kittens, you know, being little zombies, I love them.
它们的名字叫曼尼、克莱尔、海莉和奇尼·D，又名菲尔、又名下巴点点。它的下巴上有个斑点。我们开始叫它下巴点点，现在它叫奇尼·D了。它们都很棒。它们都是满分小猫。请领养它们。请领养它们。还有，我觉得今天最触动我的一点是，我们在录音室待了一会儿，当萨姆说，哦，就像《最后生还者》里的真菌时，卡西说，哦，那是什么？我只是在想这些小猫，你知道的，像小僵尸一样，我爱它们。
All right, guys, have a good Friday. Have a good Friday. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
好了，伙计们，祝你们周五愉快。祝你们周五愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是英斯利·巴巴科。Odyssey 的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。